Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
homage to the Buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so because it's spring and because the next moon day is celebrating the Buddha himself I thought it would be a nice thing to do the seven factors of enlightenment and the five spiritual faculties they double over on certain ones so what we have is
Sada which translates as confidence and that matches with insight with wisdom and then we have effort which supports concentration or focus and then we have calmness which twins with interest and then finally equanimity which twins with investigation of the dharma or the insight
And holding all that together is, of course, awareness.
So I've mixed these five spiritual faculties with the seven factors of enlightenment there.
Now, what I want to centre on is this whole quality of saddha, which translates the two words I prefer rather than faith is confidence and trust.
When I use the word confidence, I have confidence in
it seems to centre upon my relationship to what it is I'm confident in.
But when I use the word I trust, I trust the Dhamma, I trust the teaching, it seems to centre more upon what it is that I'm putting my confidence in.
So it's just me, I suppose, with words.
So it's confidence and trust, I think, gets close to the idea of this sadha, translating the Pali word.
now this is twinned with the word panya and there are three levels of this wisdom the first one is when we come to hear something so our initial interest in what we hear now that will actually give us some sort of confidence if it doesn't then of course we don't take it any further and the more confidence we have the more we'll want to read about the dharma
and the more you do that the more of course you find the opportunity to think about it and it becomes your own bit of intellectual knowledge and then finally that leads us into the actual practice the vipassana which is the final stage of this process of insight and it's through vipassana that these things are realized by us they become our own personal experience so that is all supported with
this confidence this trust and if that begins to fade then of course you find yourself losing interest now what is the uh enemy of that of course is doubt and um this is a sort of skeptical doubt it's not the doubt that the buddha wants us to have which which raises up that interest a sense of wonder you know is the buddha right about this
This skeptical doubt is what stops you doing things.
And it's often because of fear of failure, or it could be because you're fearful of it undermining your treasured opinions.
So for instance, if you are committed to scientific materialism, and it turns out that there is a transcendence, then of course that does undermine your position a bit.
And that's always fearful for us because
we identify ourselves with our opinions and our views.
So sometimes this skeptical doubt will just stop us, you know, mid-tracks.
It'll just stop us from doing something.
Now, the other doubt that we can have is in the Buddha himself and of course in the teacher, heaven forbid.
But that doesn't mean that we should not lose our critical faculties of the teacher.
You know, we're not supposed to be enslaved to our teachers.
And often we lose certain confidence in the practice.
And I think that comes because we have some idea of progress.
And if it doesn't fit our idea of progress, then you think, oh, well, you know, the teaching doesn't work.
And often it turns back into us that, you know, it works for some, but not for me.
I'm no good.
I'm useless at this.
So there's also a doubt in oneself and that comes often about by comparison.
You see somebody who started with you and they're fully liberated and you're still hanging around being depressed and anxious.
So that tends to, you tend to think, well, I can't do it.
Everybody else can, but I can't.
So these types of doubts have to be undermined.
by you know recognizing the wrong view the wrong reason as to why doubt has arisen and of course that doubt will be completely undermined by really through the practice and no matter how little the insight is that insight is supporting our confidence so that final point about the self
The whole teaching of the Buddha leads to the conclusion that everybody must become liberated.
It's not possible for anybody not to become liberated, no matter how long it takes, because that which is trying to understand why it is suffering and seeking the end of suffering is what is actually liberated by that process.
So we can say that it's a categorical imperative.
It's an absolute must that whether you want to or not, like it or not, we will be driven towards full liberation and awakening.
So there's a bit of hope there for us all.
So just finally, this confidence, we can develop it.
We can develop a confidence in the Buddha, for instance.
Now that's if you've got a sort of devotional heart.
So you read about the Buddha.
You can imagine yourself listening to the Buddha when you're reading the scriptures.
Actually now, a lot of the scriptures are
uh on on youtube as um just delivered by somebody there's a couple of websites that do it too so there are certain ways in which you can develop a relationship with the historical buddha uh with the developing in the dharma of course is really just you know not expecting great progress just keep at it little by little and the sangha uh that's our other
uh commitment should we say is uh recognizing that you know there are people who are progressing there are people who are fully liberated uh even now there's uh there's somebody in thailand called adjan oh dear come on memory memory don't worry there is a an adjan in thailand ganha that's his name adjan ghana
who is recognized as fully liberated and he is a nephew of Ajahn Chah for those of you who know Ajahn Chah.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and they have not caused even greater confusion and that by your commitment to the practice you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.